is serial monogamy
what you would
guess
ancestrally is this sort of i guess
natural state of affairs on average
no
not really um
for humans it appears to be something
more chimpanzee-like which is
uh
polygamy in some form either
promiscuous polygamy is it it kind of is
in chimney
um well it it i suppose just think in
terms of the way chimpanzees uh
society works the the males fight it out
amongst themselves
and the the the top dog then gets to
mate with all the females and this
doesn't mean to say that the males
further down the hierarchy don't uh
occasionally mate with females
they often do they try and sneak them
off into the bushes where nobody's
watching
um but
they don't have a sort of permanent
relationship
the females rear the their offspring are
aided by the males and males may be
contributing by defending a territory or
something like that or keeping other
males strange males away from the group
but the males aren't really particularly
involved in
in child care and child rearing
you might get some relationships that
last longer there's a tendency
for these kind of systems you see this
in the gorillas particularly where
several females are locked onto one male
so the males
in those sort of contexts are
functioning
as kind of
sumo wrestlers if you like they're the
big thugs that keep everybody else off
you off your back
sperm donor and bodyguard
absolutely and this is sometimes known
as the bodyguard hypothesis
um
and we kind of see that in humans too a
little bit
um but by and large most human societies
are actually polygamous let's say you
have a male with several wives have you
got an idea of the upper bound of that
um
well if you look at some of the famous
uh um emea's of
morocco places or
um you know the the um
uh emperors of uh uh the the mughal
state in in
in north india can run into king solomon
i suppose is the other famous example
run into many hundreds if not thousands
of
wives and concubines between them um
but on the whole the problem is that you
know if you have a few few males doing
that that means there's an awful lot of
males at the bottom of the hierarchy who
don't get a wife period
um unless they go around stealing them
from
uh you know other cultures
and either of the other tribes either of
those make for a pretty unstable society
it it makes for a very unstable society
and one of the consequences of this
in almost all these societies
historically is
when the grand old man dies he's got
like a hundred sons
all of whom are gunning for each other
um to
be take his places the next emperor so
there's an absolute bloodbath usually of
of rivals because to the victor the
spoils to the victor all the spoils and
the spoils are very very rich indeed in
these cases
it's not unusual i mean that's basically
what happened on under
the saxon kings in england and it
happened in scotland with the scottish
kings really
quite late running through into the 12
uh or even thirteen hundreds um you know
they
they were just you would just end up
with
an almighty um
mess basically as different families
fought over
who who was going to be the next the
next king sometimes while the king
previously was still alive
and he didn't survive much longer
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]